fed prepares another mega size rate hike
uh raising risking deeper economic
downturn uh fed policymakers remain
laser focused on bringing inflation
under control as higher prices prove
persistent even if it triggers a
recession fetch chairman jerome powell
told reporters last month that failing
to restore price stability would be a
bigger mistake than crushing growth and
causing a downturn central bank
policymakers raised the benchmark
interest rates by 75 basis points in
june for the first time since 1994 and
signaled that another increase of that
magnitude is possible in july but 100
basis point rate hike uh could be also
on the table now didn't they announce
that they did three quarters of a point
because this is not saying they did yet
this this may have been yesterday
morning and they did it yesterday
afternoon okay so check check to see if
they may be announced i thought they
already raised it no they did a month
ago and now this is another i know i
thought there was another one yesterday
yeah that's correct put a did that go
through i thought yes put news
tyler i think it was the reporters yeah
okay so go up a little bit let's read
the article about that fund's rate is
now what two and a quarter that's
correct two and a half yeah multiply by
three round down a bit that's usually
mortgages
multiple times three and round down a
bit so what's two and a quarter times
three is six point seven five round down
a little bit there's your third oh it's
crazy that just breaking news from cnn
u.s mortgage rates have now dropped you
wouldn't expect that to happen why right
the 30-year fixed mortgage rate falls to
5.3 this is down from 5.54
a week before in persipine new york for
805 credit make sure you get the whole
thing
it does not say that okay in persipine
new york this is this kind of fun facts
that tom will drop on all of a sudden
and no one in the world has been
persephone except like 18 000 people
okay so okay so let me ask you what do
you think's happening over here with
these rates tom because because the
biggest thing i want to ask you thomas
the following
rates go up three-quarters of a point
dow blows up yesterday after the
announcement what the hell is going on
i think there's two things going on the
first thing is that the fed only has so
many weapons in its arsenal remember
it's just the fed
and
the solution
for
uh inflation is to make the dollar more
valuable so the price of the dollar
which is interest rates has to go up
it's academic it goes back a bazillion
years it's complicated by money supply
m1 m2 which we've really juiced in the
past five years and so that's there now
there are other things that go into the
market
you know going up because you have a lot
of things in commodity oil oil price and
everything so that's everything from
plastics to fuel so the market yesterday
i i don't think you can say market up
yesterday and fed rate announcement
yesterday worked perfectly correlated
because i think what you're about to see
is you're already seeing in the second
quarter announcements that have been
going on for the past two weeks miss
miss miss miss facebook had had its
first down
quarter uh year-over-year quarter
shopify
18 points down yeah what does that say
about e-commerce purchases exactly so
that's another so that's a broad online
retail we already know retail's really
in trouble americans have stopped buying
predominantly and now we see online
retail with shopify so
i think yesterday the two announcements
were not correlated and i trust what all
the second quarter ceos have been saying
which is i got headwinds and i'm uh i'm
guiding down and interest rates are
going to make it worse
let me say something political uh and
because i'm i i learned listening to him
um i think trump is going to announce in
early the mid-september
and i've got a contrarian view of this i
think this is still his party pat
and i think he generally clears the
field i still don't believe desantis
would challenge him
i think the voters look all republican
insiders [ __ ] the wall street journal
and all these republican consultants who
don't want trump to run and they don't
and most of my former colleagues in
congress privately don't want to run but
[ __ ] all them it's up to the voters and
i think the voters in the republican
party right now are still with trump so
i think when he announces in early
september i think he clears the field so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]